nathan's with us in universal city texas
hi nathan how are you doing good sir
yourself
better than i deserve how can i help yes
sir so my question is
is it wise to share a room with my
girlfriend
so my company is sending me on a trip to
maui
i won summit this year um so they're
sending me for a week
and i get to take one other person with
me um i'd like to take my girlfriend
with me
but i don't know if it's a wise
decision to lodge in the same bedroom
okay are you all already living together
sleeping together
no sir okay so this will be violating
that right
right we're trying to abstain until
marriage yes sir okay
uh and how old are you sir 25
okay um
i mean you you certainly can do whatever
you want but you're asking me which is a
mistake because i'll tell you so
um i would get a separate yeah i'd get a
separate bedroom
because uh if i'm 25 years old i don't
have that much willpower
right i mean really you're just asking
for
a situation that apparently based on
you're telling me what your values are
that you're gonna regret
you're just asking for trouble
right on top of that um
i don't really care how people think
about the way it looks but i care about
the way something looks for my wife
and i don't want to compromise her
reputation and i'm going to guess and
say
if you're concerned about this kind of
thing like i would be
uh we share that value system then i
would be concerned about what people
thought about my wife
that's a true statement yes sir yeah so
i mean like her dad
right mainly her dad honestly
[Laughter]
yeah and uh you know because you know
ever
all of us guys are going yeah you might
pull that off but you probably won't
[Laughter]
you know and why put yourself through
that oh my gosh
uh so no as a matter of reputation
of the lady that you love we'll be very
old-fashioned here we're going to
protect her reputation
to her dad to her friends because you've
made this statement that you're going to
wait until marriage
then let's let's put a situation in
place that leaves no one questioning
that you did
much less uh having to have that kind of
self-discipline
which uh 25 there was no chance
oh so nathan you're a good young man you
have a good heart
we need more people like you in america
today there are so few of you
thank you sir i'm honored to speak with
you today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
yes there are people out here like me
that are dinosaurs that actually believe
that we're supposed to be married
before we engage in sexual activity like
that
yeah it's it's i know it's i know it's
hard to believe for some of you
you can't grasp the concept but it's a
part of my christian faith i actually do
believe that i didn't always i wasn't
always a christian
and it's my faith has informed me on
that and it's not a
not a question in my mind but it seems
to be a foreign
concept in a culture that has become so
toxic
a foreign concept so uh does my
does my old heart my old dinosaur heart
good to talk to a nathan that is
actually concerned
gallant young gentleman concerned about
his fiancee and actually cares
what her dad thinks what a man of honor
oh don't we need more men of honor
and more women of honor men of virtue
women of virtue they're getting more and
more rare
it's almost like having a superpower
nowadays